el proceso por la corrupción contra el
ex presidente francés nicolas sarkozy
quedó aplazado esto porque uno de los
tres acusados no estuvo presente en la
apertura de esta audiencia se trata de
gilbert al cíber el magistrado de 74
años en su lugar fue su abogado quien
presenta un certificado médico
explicando que su cliente tiene una
salud bastante frágil y que para él
venir desde burdeos hasta parís para
asistir a este proceso en medio de una
pandemia cuando ha tenido problemas
respiratorios pues puede generar un
mayor riesgo para su salud durante
varios minutos la corte debatió acerca
de qué decisiones deberían tomar y
finalmente decidieron que el juicio
quedaría aplazado solamente de unos días
mientras se le hace un examen por
peritos o médicos por expertos a médicos
a aliviar por su parte el fiscal a cargo
pues él pidió que se tenga la
consideración que tal vez a libia pueda
seguir este proceso por videoconferencia
esto también se sabrá el día jueves por
su parte nicolás adjudica ya los odio a
quienes son los otros dos acusados en
acaso si estuvieron presentes al
expresidente francés se le vio en
realidad bastante seguro un poco agitado
en la sala incluso respondió con un poco
de altivez a la presidenta de la corte
cuando ésta le pidió que se diera su
identidad se le vio muy seguro en todo
caso de la estrategia de defensa que ha
trabajado junto con su abogada es
reclinada el lazo en todo caso este
proceso debe retomar este próximo jueves
a la 1 30 de la tarde hora de país